le gouvernement a pris des mesures
extrêmes et peut-être extrêmement
désordonnée ou peut être extrêmement
plus rationnelle cela dit quand
j'entends dire on va finir par dire une
personne 70 ans qui arrive à l'hôpital
on va pas la prendre mais c'est qu'on
fait c'est ce qu'on a fait pendant le
confinement pour les gens qui avaient
des cancers ou autre chose on l'a fait
en réalité donc il se doit c'est pour
dire qu'il a des contradictions qui sont
extrêmement difficiles
de la même manière quand j'entends dire
on n'a pas le courage s'attaquer aux
lieux privés mais comment voulez-vous
vous avez pas envoyer la police chez des
gens pour voir s'ils sont plus de 6 à
table et il respecte bien au moins un
mètre de distance c'est bien joli de
dire ça mais c'est quand même
extrêmement difficile à réaliser
donc le gouvernement un peu dans
l'affolement probablement de cette
deuxième vague qui n'étaient pas prévus
aussitôt le gouvernement prend des
mesures et des mesures je vois je vous
accorde qu elles ne sont pas toujours
forcément les meilleurs mais alors
comment faut-il faire et ce qu'il faut
panel de citoyens papa tout scientifique
bien entendu pour décider quelles sont
les mesures vivable et des mesures pas
vivable
moi je crois qu'il faut partir de
l'économie parce que l'arrêt de
l'économie est un drame nous avons déjà
plus d'un million de chômeurs seuil de
pauvreté qui est monté considérablement
et la deuxième chose je le disais même
la chose aussi essentiel c'est l'école
il faut tout faire pour que l'école et
j'entends par là jusqu'à l'université
puisse fonctionner ensuite je trouve
extrêmement dommage le disait en
commençant ce propos que les arts du
spectacle soit peut-être été très part
de soulagement quand même parce
qu'encore une fois il produit du travail
ils sont nos sommes dans l'industrie
culturelle de de la même manière et je
reviens en fait en télétravail
je m'étais rendu compte après avoir
milité pour lui qu'il y avait quand même
éventuellement aussi des abus derrière
c'est très difficile et moi j'ai parlé à
des gens jeunes j'avais chez moi une
jeune nièce que je logeais qui était en
télétravail pour des raisons précisément
logistique on se rend bien compte qu'au
bout de deux mois complets de
confinement et de télétravail
les gens ont un besoin très grand de
parler alors que le legs pas juste au
téléphone de deux je ne parle pas ici
uniquement des cas où il est utile de se
parler pour tenir pour faire son métier
faire son travail assumer ses tâches
je parle vraiment de l'environnement
psychologique général du travailleur qui
demande quand même souvent un
plus de présence
[Musique]